do you think men care about a woman's
body count do you
oh my God that's so stupid people
actually ask that
yes you okay well then you're talking to
the wrong man
if a man is ever asking about your body
count you're talking to the wrong man
and he can get like that's so stupid
because a few issues here red flags if
you're a single man looking for uh the
the woman of your dreams and someone who
might want to spend the rest of your
life with uh this this is not going to
be it before we even get to the content
of what is being said when you come
across a woman who cannot say two words
without dropping an F-bomb he can get
like that's so stupid
go go the other direction like as fast
as you can
[Music]